I really love it when you stop by you're
very friendly fella charming you are
you're from Kentucky I am I'm wondering
if that has something to do with the
fact that that I've always liked you
you're you seem like your real meat and
potatoes kind of fella but you grew up
with great value yeah yeah absolutely
yeah I mean it's you know I was born and
raised there came out here when I was
well not raised I came in here I was
nine right so parsley is out here but
yeah it's it's a great place to be from
and go back to a lot and live are you
okay are you okay living in Los Angeles
like you live here pretty much full-time
now yeah I am I mean I I have people you
really angry me about this but I have
like reverse seasonal depressive
disorder where I hate sunshine and warm
weather and it's very strange because I
wake up and it's sunny and I'm just like
I want to stay in bed all day and if I
wake up and it's cold and rainy then I'm
like let's get stuff done right right
living in California it's like it's
known for nice weather and it makes me
like physically depressed I will say
this I agree with you a hundred percent
about the fall like when the fall and
early winter that's when I was like 94
on Thanksgiving yeah I just cook the
turkey outside yeah stupid yeah my
turkey wore a string bikini exactly
that's horrible
anyway it's not great yeah the point is
I yeah I'm the same way I want to see my
breath yeah and the only way to do that
now is to smoke and smoking now yeah I
start smoking because yeah and I pretend
I'm cold and I smoke a lot of thing I
kind of Miss that static that and so
yeah you really do yeah it's it's tough
it's sad
you